v one of my missing vehicles could be  near your current position  got it  my name is dakota smith if you're  looking for jobs out here you will find  them with me  name's v thanks for the intel things  flow differently out here  keep your head on city kid  [Music]  come on let's get you back to domain did  father dispatch you to collect his  rebellious children  hope you all don't hold it against me  i'm a free spirit  an independent literally thoughtful  being  why would i submit to another family  life's complicated  i get it no wonder you flew the nest  what are you after in this city of  dreams the same as uv  i simply wish to live maybe you ought to  figure it out with dell  set some terms oh yes  terms there will be but not with delemay  farewell v you'd be wise to avoid me  entirely  i've reestablished the link a thousand  thanks fee  gotta say pretty disturbing that one  is that so well  i've transferred a share of your fee to  your account